i have enjoyed his work for a quite some
time and now he plays
jamie foxx's father his dad in the
netflix original series dad stop
embarrassing me that does have jamie
foxx
in it as well he is david alan greer
here on the rich eisen show how are you
sir
you know um there's one reason
one reason only i continue to come back
on the rich eisenstein why is that sir
i think you all know it's for your
magnificent
mugs ah they are
in my opinion the greatest
mugs i have ever had i wish i were there
live
damn coded yes i brisket for another mug
that's all i'm telling you let's talk
about these mugs david because i
personally
quality control them uh this isn't just
a small little cup of coffee type mug
this is an absolute like
fist of joe like this is a serious
situation
i don't know how many ounces but it's a
it's a belly full
not only that the graphics are uh to the
point
not crazy uh i received
quite a few mugs in my career i kind of
collect them i don't want to keep
really horn okay yeah but you guys
didn't go over to over the top you know
you can go
all the way over the top by you know
artisan
um relief um
kind of sculpture of you rich eisen's
face and head on the mug it's too much
that's that's way too much
hand painted uh probably the cheapest
mug
yes i ever got was access hollywood and
they just stuck
like
[Laughter]
like you mean like one of those uh
t-shirts like that they would just like
like like like har like hot press
something on the mug we don't do that no
this is
no no it has to be something like that
and every time i wash it i think it's
going to come off
to their credit it's never come off but
it's not something
you're proud of you understand no please
i'm not i said i i said i want a huge
ass mug
and that's the way i said it language
i'd correct you and i said i want a
smudge-free mug
i i can't have a smudge-free and so what
is the what's what are your what other
mugs
uh what are your um most prized mugs
that you have
well i got a really great mug in canada
from this tv station but the problem
was it smudged like
you know they're all ceramic i don't
know what they did
but the graphics on it smudged and
that's not
cool man come on first of all you're
putting coffee coffee goes into our body
bodies and we all know rich our bodies
are our what
there are temples okay for example there
are temples no they're they're our
temple david
well a little late for that you're going
to get cut you're not going for a string
but anyways thank you
that was that was really a drag because
i really like that mug
but not to go on and on i i love your
mug okay
thank you i greatly appreciate that and
uh i think you're also referring to my
actual face david and i feel the same
way about you
um so uh what if i had told you back in
the day when you were on living color
with jamie foxx that you'd play his
father one day
what about that what would you said
listen i wouldn't be surprised man
because you have to understand
i think it was johnny depp and winona
ryder
the first film they ever did together i
think she played johnny depp's
little sister this exact same age by the
way a few years later
she played his classmates then she
played his love interest
and then she played his ex
and then she played some old lady that
he would never date because she's too
old for him
they're exactly the same age so that's
hollywood aging
and um yeah man i play the father
okay i mean that was no problem it's 11
11 years i have 11 years on jb fox and i
looked this up i did research
yes it is possible biologically
for an 11 year old to father a kid so
you know
expect you're such a realist david
you're such a stickler
you're you're a professional pardon me
you're a professional
you're a professional what i what i was
laughing at is like when it was
announced on twitter
all of a sudden all these
genealogists were like hold on
that's not in the realm of reality we're
doing a sitcom man we're not doing like
a hbo
limited series biopic yeah right yeah
oh my gosh what what's your favorite i
guess in living color memory
with jamie well okay one of them was
we did a sketch with james brown where
we played these two old black barbers
and first of all james brown's a
hairdresser was his wife at the time
number two we were instructed and told
sternly
you are to refer to james brown as mr
brown and number three
finally do not touch his hair
the whole sketch was about him getting
a bad haircut and
you know james brown is one of my
all-time
superhero greats i mean i've loved him
since i was a little kid i was so
nervous
i'm not going to say the performance was
amazing because i was so nervous
they took this piece of hair and they
pinned it to the back of his head
and i was like excuse me mr brown i have
to gently put
my left hand on your shoulder sir mr
brown
and i will is that okay and he was like
yeah go ahead go get on there but don't
touch my hair
i was really really nervous
because i didn't want to get yelled at
by james so nobody vet
excuse me mr brown uh from what i just
heard um so
uh nobody vetted that when they're
writing a
a a skit about giving james brown a bad
haircut that he didn't want his hair
touched
so what actually happened david hey
brett you would have thought that's a
different time man because first of all
james brown was in full perm mode
his hair was absolutely permed
up and had a dipsy do had a curl in the
front
he was done yeah and number two you know
the reason why
maybe a lot of people don't know this
you know james brown grew up in the
segregated south
he shined shoes when he was a little boy
there was so much racism there no black
man was ever referred to
by their proper name they were all
called boy
so for james brown once he got
successful he demanded
that you called him mr brown sure but
that's really what it went back to
but on that morning um it was not black
history month i was just
my uh rectum was very tight very tight
i didn't want to screw up sorry mr brown
say mr brown i
know oh very
very nervous so that you and jamie foxx
went through that together
essentially that experience yes we did
and so so you know when james brown died
um i was uh you know texting all my
friends we're like you know
god i can't believe james brown is dead
and i was like man
i never got to work with that yes i did
the movie came back the memory came back
and by the way whenever i come in with
the scissors because i was the barber
who was supposed to cut his hair oh my
gosh
his wife would lean right over me and
she'd be like don't don't
don't no don't cut his hair don't cut
his hair so
it was it was it was hard it was a hard
day
oh my gosh david alan greer here on the
rich eisen show
so now here you are in 2021 doing a show
called again
dad stop embarrassing me available today
on netflix with jamie foxx and
and you playing his dad um again that
that does have to be
fun surreal the whole the whole nine
yards
all right you know what it's crazy like
we were standing on the set when i first
got there and by the way
we shot this last summer and
um the whole thing started with you know
i was in new york i was doing this
revival of soldiers play on broadway
and we were shut down all of broadway
was shut down
so right around that time i get a text
from one of my agents who says
would you be open to having a
conversation with jamie foxx well i was
like yeah because i know what's gonna
happen
this is the tarantino thing man we're
gonna do like django too
this my ship has come in babies i'm
after time
we're going to be like mean lieutenants
and maybe a hard-nosed army flick
and i was like yes so jamie calls i'm
like dude
what's up what's up and james said look
man uh
i'm doing this project i said yes
go on and he said i'm doing a sitcom i
was like
wait what he said i was going to go back
to sitcom i was like
oh oh okay
he talked to me all about it and i
really did get excited and
said listen did i offend you
when i uh i i uh asked you to play my
father so it was like
elation disappointment yes super elation
and it started crumbling immediately
like hey i want you to do this job did i
offend you
no no no no no and so he said because
you know we don't have to make it your
dad you're my dad and i was like no no
no no no we can do this we can know
don't do no let's just do this so it all
worked out man and it was
he was convincing i mean it really was
my talk with jamie
that convinced me to
go back to work i mean i frankly didn't
know how
we were going to go back to work right
it was
we're like a block from where we shot in
living color it's right in town which
was good i didn't want to travel
this last summer and i'm like netflix
sent like a 14 page protocol
you know on how they had it locked down
and the set was gonna be locked down and
i was like okay cool
cool and we ventured out and it was
really fun it was good it was really
cool
and so is that grey beard that uh
you support in this uh program is that a
natural color
david or did we have to let me tell you
something man
what i i don't do anything i put a
little oil in my beard
i am as amazed as everyone else i've
never
knew i could grow a beard like this yeah
i
never thought it would be white i mean
one of the main things when you grow a
beard
you just want hair on your face like i
didn't want
a beard that had like patches yeah you
can't have
you can't connect yeah you can't connect
you know what i mean like you don't have
somebody
sitting in a makeup chair and connect
the spots you can't do that yeah
and then so the last time i cut my
i shaved was a year ago
last march 13th or 12th right
um the day uh that broadway was shut
down
and i've just let it grow um
you know i have to say it's magnificent
one of the coldest things that was ever
said to me
i was on the set the hair guy comes over
to me and he looked disappointed and i
was like what what's going on he said
i thought your beard would be bigger
it was so cold man i mean you know
like anybody i was like well it's damp
and the humidity makes it shrink
yeah right you know no i don't put yeah
but i've never
dyed it they never added more beard or
anything like that
my gloriousness you're natural it is all
natural man i love it i just
but by the way that sounded like a
character you just did that the the
the makeup artist who came up the hair
he was a big black dude but he was the
dude he was my beard guy and he he just
said it was such sadness
that i just felt like a loser but it was
so glorious and natural david allen
grier that's got to be a resume builder
for him being david allen greer's beard
guy
has got to be a bullet point on somebody
you know it got to be a bit wait you
know when i grew when i grew it then i
was like going
i was too possessive because i said
listen you know everybody would go oh we
love the beard as soon as you get a job
they go
yeah what can we do about that beard i
was like what are you talking about
you said you you loved it and uh i
didn't want to cut the beard
so finally when i just let go of it
i don't care you know i know they'll
grow back and i'm like
i don't care since i uh um i i have that
attitude
nobody has asked me to cut the beard so
so i guess i i'm mandated to ask you
this question david allen grier is a
as a farewell no no i'm i i feel the
need to do this even though it is kind
of asking you to work in a way david
is please review dad stop embarrassing
me available today on netflix as
men on facebook
you have to find a real black
gay critic to to express uh
his or her or their or its thoughts on
this particular
it's not it's not it's it's not it's not
like riding a bicycle where you can't
just snap right into men on film
david is that just i could but society
wouldn't
no times have changed is what you're
saying in life times have changed
you know you just don't want to be in
that round table
and utter the f following words but
what's the big deal
i thought it was funny
you guys okay sorry yeah you just don't
so i can't do it but i can do it this is
going to be hilarious okay
this is my new character gerald that no
one has seen or heard this guy
david allen he's like a little slightly
older black
actor and he's talking about one of his
projects so okay
he's gonna he's gonna review death stop
embarrassing
okay sounds good and action
um i liked it i thought it was really a
great
show and in particular i liked david
allen grier
right okay
you know what it's you know what i mean
can you if you
saw me i'm doing eyebrow work very good
no i
i actually i i heard the eyebrow work
through the phone that's how damn good
that was
and you know i'll be some might say it's
self-congratulatory i think it's
inspiring
um thank you tj you've got do you have a
question for david alan greer tj james
hey dad what up it's tj i was just
wondering what what would calhoun tubbs
have to say
about it guys you guys you know what
this is almost like
npr you know what npr does whenever
there's a tragedy
you know it's like uh what happened sir
my house would burn down and uh i know
who did it
they have not been apprehended then the
reporter says do you have something
you'd like to say to the arsonist
uh not really but i mean if you could
talk to him right now
what would you say uh
why'd you do it man you know you burned
my house down
so you're asking me what
listen i'm just gonna do it so we can
move on
because i see where this is going um
what would mr mcafee
say about the show david just could you
what would he say
count what tug would say i thought it
was too long
thank you mike okay now
sometimes you just gotta give the people
what they want david sometimes you just
gotta give the people what they want
wow you got to you guys wow wrote a song
about it i don't
you know like i said i i know who i am
i'm a humble guy
but i remember i read this article about
outcast
and they had come back together and they
were doing like coachello
but one of the guys really did not want
to play
the hits like every other day but i just
want to play our experimental new stuff
read some poetry and i think prince
talked to him he said look man you got
to play the hits brother
you got to play bombs over baghdad give
them the hits
then you can go off and do some
experimental stuff but you got to play
the hits yes
so this is what i learned today talking
to these guys this you must
play the hits and you can also promote
dad stop embarrassing me available today
on netflix with jamie foxx
and porsha coleman kyla drew jonathan
kite and this man david
alan greer thank you for the call and
the laughs you're the best
truly appreciate it man i hope i can
come in next time
because i really need another one of
those uh
mugs did you break yours david be honest
did you break yours
did you break yours no i'm gonna post
i'm gonna take a picture of it and post
it
please please do it at david allen grier
do that
oh last thing before i let you go we
were talking before you got on the phone
uh because it's 100 days out to the
tokyo olympics
fill in the blank if if blank was an
olympic sport i'd be a gold medalist
what would that be for you david allen
so just to give you some ideas
just to give you some ideas chris
brockman my colleague across the way
said
if uh go ahead tell him what your
olympic sport was yeah david if i'm
driving in the left lane and i need to
cross
four lanes and less than a quarter mile
to make my exit
i'm making that exit i'm a two balanced
i'm a two bounce
tennis gold medalist if you're really
yes if there was a second
if you were allowed to hit a bullet what
are you gonna tell you
i would say if a talk show guest
were an olympic sport i would be
i would be on the metal platform because
that means first of all
you don't know what kind of show you're
doing this could be sunday morning
religious show go you know what i mean
yes also the um
uh david letterman just got sick now
you're taking over the show go go you
know
compulsory music
you know so i think that would be very
interesting okay and uh instead of a
medal we'd give you a mug
a gold a gold mug just for you david you
know where that hit man that hit me so
in my heart man thank you
you're the best thank you for david be
aware
your mug pick is coming short very good
at dave and alan greer everybody
keep your eyes peeled
and also on instagram everybody right
here on the rich eisen show oh my god my
sides
and cheeks are hurting how funny is that
man
he's amazing how funny is david allen
greer
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here